Stanford and there we have it president
zielinski uh Dressed in like a dark
brown Richie sunac in his suit now
walking up Downing Street to the shouts
of photographers
[Music]
the two men
do you feel Britain backs is vaccube
foreign
just across your screen you're seeing a
whole load of uh Ukrainian and other
media uh run past it and then the entire
president zelensky team now making a
second uh the door of Downing Street
about to open uh for a second time with
President zolenski's Aid security uh
figures you can hear actually Applause
from behind the doors in Downing Street
something that you normally get when you
get a new prime minister really quite
loud cheers and Applause uh inside
number 10 through that black door as
those people that have made the journey
from Key all the way here to Westminster
to Downing Street uh step on the red
carpet security
officials diplomats who have made the
journey with some of those guarding
president zolinsky staying on the
outside and and and I think it's
important just to reflect the sheer
significance of this moment this is a
war president who has only made two
trips outside his country the first to
the United States of America to address
Congress and a brief stop off in Poland
on the way back and then the second trip
today to the United Kingdom to
Westminster to see the British prime
minister the British king United Kingdom
King Prince Charles III uh other
political leaders and to show his thanks
for the way in which the UK has really
rallied behind Ukraine